[Music]
which Souls born bossfight includes
this sound effect is it a mirga's
wetness be ceaseless discharge see gyobu
masataka honey wha what D Osiris the
consumed King vote now no hey don't look
at the comments okay is that your final
answer all right the answer is B
ceaseless discharge that is the same
sound effect as this it's just slowed
down and given a lower pitch truth is
ceaseless is an infant he was tragically
transformed in izalith while the chaos
flame was still unstable the fact that
his voice is just modified from that of
an actual baby makes this sad story even
sadder deep in the design works of Dark
Souls lies another secret from this area
his name is King izalith and he was
originally going to be the main boss of
this area sitting on a throne lording it
over the bed of chaos that was to arrive
beneath him this concept is very
obviously inspired by the old monk of
demon souls who sits above his arena in
much the same way and in turn the old
monk looks very much like xanthus King
Jeremiah who was a man exiled to the
painted world so it's almost certain
that Jeremiah is or at least was at one
point the king of izalith in addition to
the old monk connection there are two
other things first he uses chaos
pyromancies which were developed by the
witches of izalith and he especially
uses chaos flame whip which was wielded
by the eldest daughter alone and second
remember that wall hugging parasite in
Blighttown that guards power within in
the text files of the game this thing is
called Prince izalith which really
leaves little suspicion as to what kind
of Paris
the xanthus king is hiding beneath his
bloodied yellow headpiece another NPC
that was originally intended to be a
boss fight was master willem who sits on
the Bergen worth balcony overlooking
ROMs lake in cut content Willem
proclaims this desperate need for more
eyes and then he decides that your eyes
will do perfectly precious sacrifice in
his boss mode Willem begins speaking in
tongues he summons projectiles and he
slams his chair down in this unnatural
creepy manner to damage the player with
some sort of shock wave which is
unfortunately invisible alongside his
projectiles in the current state of the
game this was originally discovered by
Lance Macdonald who often features in
this series as you're probably aware so
for more on this encounter go and check
out his youtube channel lance revealed
another piece of cut content this year
and this time it's centered on the
yharnam stone which is kind of at once
the toughest item to find in blood-borne
and also the most useless but it wasn't
always this way you get this item from
defeating Queen Jana in the deepest
chalice dungeons and at one point if you
took it to the fishing hamlet priest he
had this to say time is not and the sea
rumbles of far and yet a mother's
pungent devotion can still be felt
thank you messenger I exude gratitude
for one such as you cos bless this
messenger this visit are from beyond but
from the fact that the priest blesses
you in this dialogue instead of cursing
you for a change
there really is little of significance
to learn from this except that in this
place outside of time and outside of
space the devotion of another mother can
still be felt for it is the destiny of
all of the great ones to lose their
children and just as cause lost her
often so too did Queen Yanam have Mogo
taken from her it's a shame really that
this no longer exists in game because an
accomplishment like killing Queenie on
and really does deserve something even
if it's just this little line of
dialogue and as of November 18th 2019
every single chalice dungeon has been
explored and documented because counter
to popular belief the chalice dungeons
are actually finite and not truly
randomly generated instead each depth of
chalice dungeon pulls from a hard-coded
selection of rooms with a total of 2,300
possible dungeons each one of them
additionally modified by effects and
rites that make them look a bit
different so thanks to the folks over at
the tomb prospectors reddit we now have
this exhaustive list of all the effects
gems bosses and discoveries inside of
these places all of which can be found
in the description below congratulations
on this monumental achievement as we all
know blood-borne is heavily based on the
writings of HP Lovecraft and his cosmic
horror of the unknown and the unknowable
the best example of this commonly
referenced is the fishing Hamlet
it's similarities to love crafts shadows
over Innsmouth story however in all the
years since blood bonds release I feel
like I've never seen anyone discussing
specifically how love crafts other
stories directly inspired different
sections of blood-borne how the dream
quest of unknown Kadath sees a man
traversing sanctuaries and nightmares
just like the hunter's dream and
nightmare realms how a handful of
stories feature cursed families who
mirror the fate of blood-borne hunters
or one of my favorites how the
expedition into the labyrinth in
Mountains of Madness somewhat inspired
the chalice dungeons listen to this
quote which I'm free to read to you at
length thanks to this video sponsorship
by audible tell me this doesn't remind
you of the chalice dungeons it is
absolutely necessary for the peace and
safety of mankind that some of the
earth's stark dead corners and unplugs
depths be let alone lest sleeping
abnormalities wake to resurgent life and
blasphemously surviving nightmares
squirm and splash out of their black
layers to newer and wider conquests
that's a quote from the mountains of
madness and there are so many stories
like this so to help you listen to them
all I managed to get an audible
sponsorship for this video with the link
below or by texting party video to 500
500 for a limited time you can get 3
months of audible for just 695 a month
which is more than half off the regular
price and every month you'll receive a
free audiobook credits that you can cash
in for anything in there enormous
library of content I've listened to
audible in my downtime for years now and
I really enjoyed that feeling of growing
my personal library bit by bit every
month so consider starting yours today
by again visiting audible.com slash
party video or by texting avati Vidia to
500 500 the audiobook that I recommend
is the complete fiction of HP Lovecraft
because it has every story and it has a
great narrator who
convincingly voices a whole cast of
characters and if you don't like this
choice for whatever reason you can
actually exchange it with no questions
asked and any audio books in their
enormous library that you do decide to
keep are yours forever
speaking of enormous libraries a
surprising number of the books in Sates
archives actually have legible titles
perhaps the most notable one is this one
it's a real book written by French
author Paul acha titled Letizia de vivre
which translates to the desire to live
pretty suitable title in a game like
this number 8 no one really ever expects
to be hit by that melancholy piano when
you first go through the final boss folk
in the kiln of the first flame it's the
climax of your journey and yet you're
facing this sad husk of a man to the
tune of this simple piano piece it's
striking from a story standpoint it's
brave as a compositional choice but also
it might be impressive technically as
well for the name Gwyn means white and
his theme is best played entirely with
all the white keys on a piano it's
likely that this took some conscious
restraint on the part of the composer
and it could even be an effort at
Madrigal ISM where they set the word
Gwyn or white to music in a way that
illustrates its literal meaning of
course it could be still coincidence but
I kind of think coincidence can still be
meaningful and I think this is one of
those times but maybe those with more
musical knowledge can weigh in on this
in the comments below
Gwyn's soul was split and given to a few
in his entourage most notably to seethe
and also the four kings however there is
one misleading statement in the English
that has to do with his four knights
whose souls read Gwyn granted this soul
to his four trusted Knights and
this actually isn't true instead these
souls are more accurately read the so
loved one that was counted among
four nights of kinguin and it's unlikely
that he granted them power in the same
manner that he did to save and the four
kings in a recent episode on semper
temple we told the story of how code
zero ends up in the illusory holes
finally reunited with the rejuvenating
children a group of invisible kids
sacrificed in experiments on immortality
and in his final scene code 0 is seen
talking to them all but you don't
actually just have to take his word for
it that they're there they actually are
as terrible as it sounds if you attack
the space where they're sitting you get
that visual effect that shows whenever
you try to kill a protected NPC they're
there and you gotta love the extra
thought that went into this speaking of
killing NPCs when you go to fight
Hawkwood in the final battle
we're met with this entitled arrogant
character who is determined to kill us
and take the Dragonstone from our person
but in the Japanese his dialogue gives a
more gentle heroic spin on the character
this is a character that we've seen shy
away from his destiny throughout the
ages never standing up for himself and
in the end instead of the English
proclaiming that he shall take that
which is rightfully his in the Japanese
he actually says something more like he
will receive recognition by defeating us
and when we defeat him he calmly states
well if you are the dragon then that
isn't so bad another character that's
deeper than most know is griggs who
really may not be who he says he is the
black sorceress said that he wears
states that there is a secret sect of
sorcerers at vinhai' academy dedicated
to covert operations and while Griggs
maintains this guise of a humble
apprentice to master Logan there really
is a lot of deception built into his
character first Griggs has a selection
of spells that you can learn from but
the only spell that is not willing to
teach to you is a spell called hush
which is a spy sorcery developed by a
nameless sorcerer at the shadow even
hime institution second
he sells two rings for accomplished
sorcerers
where's and doesn't sell the slumbering
dragon crest ring worn by the
aforementioned surreptitious sorcerer at
vin home more than this though I think
we're supposed to question his behavior
while he claims that he's an apprentice
to Logan Logan never once mentions the
apprenticeship and even when they're in
the same shrine they stand apart from
one another it's certainly clear that he
is a passionate admirer of Logan but
it's also clear that he has some murky
motivations as he shadows Logan around
Lordran still passing along information
to the vin hime school that he left
while we're in Dark Souls remastered did
you know it's possible to visit the old
battle of Stoicism
arena jump onto this ledge quit out
before dying and then reload onto the
fence
take a jump at this angle and deal there
another thing that you probably didn't
know was possible is that you can
stagger slave night Gale and even open
him up for a riposte the trick is to hit
his pea sized head whether it's with
godlike accuracy with a bow or more
likely a weapon that has a really
abnormal head box like on a kitty and
uber touchy did you ever do this when he
played the game let me know what weapon
you used and finally number 15 the
genius behind
sequitos combat system is Masuda
Yamamura its lead gameplay designer in
blood-borne also there is a character
called Yama Mora and he's an Eastern
styled character in blood-borne of all
places it makes you wonder if this all
the way back then was an early reference
to secular and a reference to the man
that would become its lead gameplay
designer Dark Souls after all also had
something like this they had the Gothic
flavoured Chester who was pulled from
another world so it makes you wonder if
he was pulled from blood-borne and if
Dark Souls was alluding to that game all
those years ago
so maybe secreto has something in it
that's alluding to Eldon ring who knows
before I go on guys again I am actually
really stoked to have audible as a
sponsor so please start your collection
on me and go and visit audible.com slash
party video or text varta video 2 500
500 if you're watching my contents we
obviously have really similar taste in
media so I'm excited to recommend you
some audiobooks that I love in the
coming months and I really want to
listen to yours as well so write them in
the comments and I'll give them a try
with all of the audible credits that
I've accumulated thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you next time